David we're coming close to the end of
Romans here for the last session we were
involved in an analysis or conversation
about Paul's excitations the paramedic
section in chapters 12 and 13 and we saw
the importance of the love command we
worried a little bit about the
eschatological or end time horizon
within which Paul thinks how wearing a
little bit about how vital it is at this
point in his career and it's certainly
there in some form or other the
exultation continues in the second half
of this ring composition with chapter 14
now can you tell us what's going on
there I can give you my best guess
first of all I just affirm what you say
that this I think is further spelling
out of how the love commandment works
now not in relation to authorities and
not in relation to enemies both of which
we've had and how does it work out in
the life of the community and I I must
say in the years that I've been studying
Romans which is not quite a few I've
gone back and forth puzzling whether
this represents Paul's knowledge of
particular issues within the Roman
Church or whether he's kind of taking
the principles he came up with in first
Corinthians and applying them on the
assumption that they always work in
first Corinthians it's it's I think
fairly clear that some of the Corinthian
Christians feel perfectly appropriate
it's perfectly appropriate to eat meat
that's been offered to idols in temple
worship and then sold on the market and
they eat it unhesitatingly other
Christians think that it's since it's
been involved that other believers think
that since has been involved in idolatry
it is idolatrous to eat it and Paul is
trying to find a way to negotiate
between those two sets of Christians and
a quick aside on that in both cases when
I'm a Baptist and growing up we always
thought strong Christians where they
don't do this don't do that
don't drink alcohol don't dance don't
play cards don't go to the movies on
Sunday for Paul those are the weak
Christians interestingly those are the
ones who have all kinds of stipulations
to go with their faith the strong
Christians are those who trust enough in
the grace of God and their own fidelity
that they don't have to get up with a
list of the do nots every morning so
it's a reversal of the way we usually
think of strong and weak Christianity so
whether out of something he knows about
the Roman churches or whether out of his
life with with the churches in Corinth
he's saying in some ways the same thing
that those of you who are strong
Christians who are not worried by
scruples about what you eat for example
should not cause those who are weak
Christians to stumble by your behavior
so that of course you're free to do all
these things but don't use your freedom
to hurt your brother or sister yeah yeah
I think you're quite right and all that
and I think the situation is probably a
little bit different from what's going
on in okay Ron Paul seems to allude to
there's some issue about vegetarianism
yeah in verse two yeah that one could
construe that as a way of abiding by
kashrut that I have played that yeah
card was a yeah it's possible that it's
analogous things like the right card or
it could be some other form of
vegetarianism it could write which works
beautifully in Berkeley where I was once
a and we know isn't popular in some
Roman circles Gentiles but there's
something else that's going on here that
suggests it might be a Jewish Gentile
thing that is the observance of service
that's what I want yeah in verse six so
it may be that some people are keeping
Shabbat and some people not and that
might be dividing the community a little
bit so Paul knows that they were these
issues but they don't seem to be at the
focal point of his attention as they the
weak strong divided they don't they
don't it does become a way of circling
back around to nine and eleven chapters
nine to eleven about what happens to
Jews and Gentiles in the larger world
then maybe thirteen and fourteen
especially fourteen or about what
happened to Jewish believers and Gentile
believers in the Roman community and I
really do
kabab my teacher Paul Minear thought
this was very much like Corinthians that
you could designate a weak party and a
strong party and I'm less convinced of
that you know I think in some ways the
the issue of vegetarianism or whatever
it is that Paul is addressing is simply
a jumping off point for the the larger
admonition that he wants to deliver in
verse 7 which is cycling back oh
absolutely
his theme of participation on Christ
living in us we do not live to ourselves
we do not die to ourselves if we live we
live to the Lord and if we die we die to
the Lord so then whether we live or
whether we die we are the Lord's
kepta Christ it's the text I use most
often when I'm preaching funerals and I
when I'm not preaching funerals but just
doing Bible study i point out that so
often with paul what looks like the most
mundane thing what are we gonna do with
vegetarians in church turns into the
most astonishing theological
affirmations so that he is he's the very
best of what a practical theologian
should be we sometimes think a practical
theologian is the one who tells you to
wash your hands before you go into the
hospital room or don't pray for longer
than a minute and a half because that
wears out the patient but the practical
theologian who says is the one who says
when you walk into the hospital room
remember if we live to the Lord we live
if we live we lived in Lord if we die we
die to Lord it's the person who brings
the whole power of the Christian story
to bear on the immediate story and I
think that's what Paul does most
powerfully mm-hmm
and still doesn't lose sight of the the
immediate and I'm sorry meat it will
simply abstract which will go on to
emphasize and they the latter part of
that that chapter does indeed yeah so
mmm this whole section in chapter 14 is
dealing with that kind of issue and then
Paul provides us a kind of summation of
his argument overall in chapter 15 yes
in two parts the first several verses
emphasizing the ethical and then in
what's going on in chapter 15 verse 7
well then then here's here is here is by
ongoing kind of pedantic puzzle which
doesn't change much about the way you
read the text in in the days when I was
most convinced that this was written out
of the particular situation of Jewish
Christians having had to leave under
Claudius and returning under Nero I
thought that the line is welcome one
another therefore as Christ has welcomed
you for the glory of God that that
specific advice you Gentile Christians
who have had the rule of the roost while
the Jewish Christians were in exile now
welcome them back as Christ as welcomes
you and becomes therefore a kind of
summation of the practical implications
of the whole gospel I don't rule that
out what our rule in is that this is one
more claim of the Paul makes all the way
through which is that the gospel is for
Jews and Gentiles alike and therefore no
Jew should boast in his or her
Jewishness and no Gentile in his or
gentleness but
that all of us rest on the mercy of God
and in the light of that mercy we are as
the saying says every every believing
community is a welcoming community
because we have ourselves been welcomed
every community is a graced community
because we have our self in graced every
community is a loving community because
we have ourselves been loved I like that
a lot it's interesting to think about
how the rhetoric of this this chapter
would work given different situations
right if he's addressing just Gentiles
welcoming to you or addressing a mixed
community and reminding them both
obligations and responsibilities and
principles on which they have to live
and I see it working in somewhat that
way and in the scriptural quotations of
verses 9 through 12 on the one side he's
affirming the Gentiles a part of this
reality though there may be folk out
there who want to deny that somewhere I
will confess you among the Gentiles and
will sing praises to your name and at
the same time every one Jew and Gentile
has to recognize the focal point of
their Allegiance in this reality and
that's given him the quote from Isaiah
in verse 12 the root of Jesse shall come
and the one who rises to rule the
Gentiles in him the Gentiles will home I
like that so yeah there's a first yeah
yeah I think I have to go back and
rewrite that article but it's marvelous
section and it includes with another
doxology or another prayer act yeah that
may the god of Hope fill you with all
joy and peace in believing so that you
may abound in hope by the power of the
Holy Spirit so that in some way seems to
conclude the the argumentative section
of Rome it doesn't do you
and then in 15 chapter 15 verse 14 and
following we have Paul talking about his
own situation do anything well I think
it circles back around to the way our
conversation started why does he write
this letter why does he feel the need to
introduce himself to these people and a
large part of this is to share with them
his itinerary which is that he's on his
way to Spain eventually he wants them to
welcome him I assume that means though
he does go back to welcome one another
PS also welcomed me
probably not a stupid way to tie those
two things together in his mind but also
his hope that they will be partners in
his spreading of the gospel and one of
the things we talked about briefly in
looking at chapters 9 to 11 is I think
his hope that within his own lifetime in
his own ministry the gospel will be
preached to the Gentiles from one end of
the Empire to the other and Spain's the
farthest west he's going to go and I
think he thinks he needs to get there
before he dies or was taken up to be
with Christ and he wants doing to engage
them as part of that ministry and in
that sense they become part of that
great woman where the Gentiles all come
in and then the Jews somewhat ashamed
come in afterwards mm-hmm yeah I
certainly think he has hopes for his
Spanish mission and we don't know what
we don't know we did it we don't know
there's a report later on in the first
century that he did go to hell yeah and
then came back to Rome to be right we
just don't know but no no actual reports
of his activity there so we have these
travel plans that tell us a lot about
his situation and writing the text and
then in chapter 16 we have what seems to
be just a long list of these huge lists
is there anything of interest in that
long list well a couple things one it's
a long list of names and so how does he
have this extraordinary long list of
names to a church where he's never been
something I thought partly for that
reason partly for funny textual reasons
that this is an add-on later than the
letter I'd like to keep it in there for
kind of theological and practical
readings and it may be that the list is
very long because if I Paul I'm
commending myself to you the leader of
the Roman Church one way to do it is to
list all the friends we have in common
I know priska Dockweiler I know the
following four people so they'll vouch
for me this is a way of saying not only
am i a good guy but I've got friends in
your court already who are Prisco and
Aquila oh there are people who've been
part of his community earlier on and we
find them in acts and they seem to
themselves travel from Corinth back here
and they were I think according to acts
among those kicked out during the
Claudius exclusion is that not right
that's right accent this kind of fits
Bartlett's little now perhaps dying
theory and of the reason for this letter
being written in the first place and
they were apparently with Paul when he
wrote first grade
fairly well when he wrote first
Corinthian so that they they are major
players in his life the other the other
piece is the nice mix between men and
women and I switched between names that
seemed to be Jewish and names it seemed
to be Gentile and for those of us who
worry about women's ordination long
before there was a question of
ordination per se
we've got chapter 16 verse 7 I commend
to you our sister Phoebe a deacon for
years that was translated as Deaconess
but it's infest verse one you mean I'm
first one 16 verse 1 sorry I commend to
you our sister Phoebe a deacon of the
Church of the King cry that means
whatever the other deacons are including
Paul sometimes she's a diaconis she's a
deacon she's a minister that may not be
an official title for oh it may not be
no it may not be at all for either of
them right it's just it's a way of
saying that the distinctions we tend to
make so wholeheartedly in the 21st
century Church between male and female
and between officer and non officer may
not have function for him and then the
trickiest of all is verse 7 greet
Andronicus and Junia a woman my
relatives who were in prison with me
relatives presume fellow Jews I think
they are prominent among the Apostles
so is Junia among the Apostles or has
just mean among the Apostles they speak
well of junior you get the same kind of
ambiguity about a woman who clearly as
woman is very important in the life of
the early church yeah I very much think
she was an apostle but given Paul sense
of what an apostle is it's not limited
to the twelve exactly was who has been
sent by exactly whatever said oh my god
as a personal experience yeah so I think
junior is up there with other apostles
so yeah I think we we learn a good deal
about the shape of the Roman community
or Paul circles from from these whether
they're in Rome or in Ephesus Osteen
maybe they the major options here and I
share yours your hunch that they
probably are in Rome but they've also
been traveling around exactly Intel is
that it's a peripatetic community from
the beginning which explains why we've
got letters to all kinds of places still
preserved and why we have a church and
isn't it great that we have this letter
from it is this is a letter to whom I
my allegiance